they were the ultimate power couple
together they created a charitable
foundation more than 20 years ago
it went on to spend more than 36 billion
pounds
fighting diseases from malaria to polio
and more recently covet 19.
in 2016 their work around the world was
recognized by president barack obama
who awarded them the presidential medal
of freedom
now bill and melinda gates say they are
separating
in identical statements posted on social
media they said
over the last 27 years we have raised
three incredible children
and built a foundation that works all
over the world to enable people to lead
healthy
productive lives we continue to share a
belief in that mission
and we'll continue our work together at
the foundation
but we no longer believe we can grow
together as a couple
in this next phase of our lives
according to forbes magazine bill gates
is the fourth
wealthiest person in the world he made
his money from microsoft which he
co-founded in 1975
and turned into one of the world's most
valuable technology firms
bill and melinda met at the company in
1987
and married seven years later well we
were
engaged to be married and after we'd
taken our first trip to africa actually
a vacation we were walking on the beach
and we committed at that point that we
were going to give the vast majority
of the resources for microsoft back to
society just it was the right thing for
us to do
last year their foundation committed
more than 1.2 billion pounds to covert
19 relief
and they've been vocal about the need
for vaccine equity
in an interview with sky news bill gates
sent this message to the world's richest
nations
the us and the uk will be the first
countries that'll have the
excess vaccines and will you know use
these mechanisms
to get them out to where the death rate
is the highest
while the couple are separating they say
the foundation will remain intact
and so too will their legacy together
aisha zahid sky news